[Music]
fully on CBS this morning we are psyched
to announce this year's finalists for
the 2019 grammy music educator award ten
teachers from 10 different schools all
around the country were chosen for their
significant and lasting contributions to
music education nearly 3000 nominations
were submitted from all 50 states
it was narrowed down to 10 so this
morning we say congratulations to you
Jeremy Bradstreet victor de los santos
elizabeth herring Henry Miller M Rangel
Jeffrey reading Scotch Ian Mickey Smith
jr. Craig Snider and last but certainly
not least there's John Witherspoon the
music educator award winner will be
honored during Grammy week will take
home a $10,000 prize the remaining
finalists will each take home a $1,000
prize plus all ten finalists schools
will receive matching grants the 61st
Grammy Awards will air Sunday February
10th right here on CBS those educator
words are always one of my favorite part
to see we always do a story on that so
we always will know you and them give
you the whole story because these are
worth highlighting these educators